I want to begin in volume 12, February the 24th, 1919.
Man is the master piece of the creative power, Jesus says.
As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus on coming said to me, my daughter, you've said
nothing about the creation of man. Jesus said, my daughter, you've said nothing about the
creation of man, the masterpiece of the creative power, in whom not in sprays, but in waves and
rivers. The eternal one poured his love, his beauty, and his mastery. And taken by an excessive love,
he placed himself at the center of man. So that's why I give you one Corinthians 3, 16,
and one Corinthians 6, 16. No, you're not that you are the temple of the living God,
and that the Spirit of God dwells in you. So the Lord created us for a particular purpose.
But God wanted a worthy dwelling place, because I gave you Hebrews 12, 14 many times that nothing
unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God. So God wanted a worthy dwelling place.
So what does this uncreated majesty do? He creates man in his own image and likeness.
That's Genesis 1, 27, and Romans 8, 29. And he draws a breath from the depth of his love,
that Ruach Adonai, or UACH, A-D-O-N-A-I, the Spirit of God. He drew a breath from the depth of his
love. And with his omnipotent breath, he infused life into man as Genesis 2, 7. He infused life
into him, endowing him with all of his qualities, proportioned to a creature, making him a little
God. So first of all, I want to give you Sam 8, 5, and Sam 82, 6, which is quoted by Jesus in John
10, 34. I said, "You are God's, all of you sons of the most high." So I said, "You are God's,"
that's small G. And in the Hebrew, it is Elohim. And when you speak about the triune God,
the Hebrew gives you Elohim with a capital E, because God can only make creatures like himself.
So he made him a little God. So everything you see in creation was absolutely nothing compared
to the creation of man. This is a most astonishing statement. "Oh, how many more beautiful heaven stars
suns," he extended in the created soul. So the soul of man is a whole creation by itself.
And when we come to the Lord and give ourselves truly to the Lord, St. Paul calls us a new creation,
as 2 Corinthians 5, 7, I think it is, a new creation. So there's a whole creation inside of us.
So there's something about the creation of the universe that reflects something about its creator.
There's something in us that reflects the one who created us. That's the universe inside of us.
And he said, "How much variety of beauty and how many harmonies he put there?" Well, even if you
examine the miracle of sight that we have, it is an extraordinary harmony of beauty that is actually
there. So when you examine how the ear works, when you examine how the brain works, when you
examine how the lungs or the kidneys or any other part of the body works, it's totally fascinating.
"How much variety of beauty," he said, "how many harmonies are there?"
It's enough to say that God looked at the man he created, and he found him so beautiful as to
be enamored with him. And jealous of this beautiful creation that he had made. So the Lord was jealous
of the creature that he had made. You'll find that in Exodus 20 verse 5, and you'll find it in
Deuteronomy 6, 15. So he made himself the custodian of man that he himself would take care of the
creature that he had made. He also made himself the possessor of man, because if you make something,
you have the right to possess it. And so we are God's possession. But because of the tragedy that
happened in the fall of man, and they dreadfully long and tragic journey that the human race has
to come back to God, we don't come back to possession of God until we reach union with him.
And it's a very long journey for most people, and indeed for the whole human race itself. So God
made himself both the custodian and the possessor of man. And he said, "I created everything for you."
Now you'll read that in Genesis 1, 28 to 30, where a description of the wonderful garden that God
created from man is given to you. "I give you dominion over everything. Everything is yours,
and you, you will be mine." So God gave us the whole earth. He put man as the king of the earth.
He put everything under his feet at Sam 8. What is man that you would even think of him, Lord?
Because you are so great that you created the heavens just with your fingers.
And yet the extraordinary thing is that you made us little less than a God, and crowned us with
glory and honor. He put everything under our feet. It's an incredible thing that he said,
"Everything was created for you. I give you dominion over everything. Everything is yours,
but you are mine." Now that's the bit that man rebels against. Man likes being God. Man in fact
followed the pattern of his seducer, Satan, because Satan rebelled and wanted to be God himself,
not somebody like God. And when he seduced Adam and Eve, he told them, "You will be like God as well."
And this God thing is inside of us that we want to behave like gods. You see that in particularly
in emperors and kings and people in charge of countries and companies and all kinds of things.
They act as if they're gods, but we are meant to be his. Jesus continued, "You will not be able
to understand everything. You will not be able to understand the seas of love and the intimate
and direct relations and contacts the likeness that actually runs between the creator and the
creature." But God can only make something like himself. So there's something in us that reflects
him. "Add author of my heart," Jesus said. "If the creature knew how beautiful her soul is,
how many divine qualities it contains, and how among all created things, it surpasses
everything in beauty, in power, and in light. So much so that it can be said that this is a little
God." There's your Sam 8, 5, and Sam 82, verse 6 again. And this is a little world which contains
everything within itself. "Oh, how much more she would esteem herself and would not dirty with
the slightest sin, a beauty so rare, so portentous a prodigy of the creative power."
Now as we go on in these volumes, you'll hear Jesus saying that he expands our interior and he
creates new suns and moons and stars and new universes inside of us. We just have to accept that he says
that if you can actually grasp it, it'd be wonderful. But the creature he said in its present condition
is almost blind to knowing who she is and much more blind to knowing who her creator is.
And that's why the human race continuously gets herself into terrible trouble.
And so the creature keeps darting herself among a thousand filthy things to the point of
disfiguring the work of her creator. But of course that's exactly what the enemy of God and man wants.
Satan wants us to dirty ourselves to the point where we're not fit for the kingdom of God anymore
and we will lose the incredible immeasurable inheritance that's been given to us.
So much so that she can barely be recognized. So there you've got the image of the prodigal son
in Luke 15. And you know when he starts off in his father's house and has such an incredible
family and inheritance and future and everything and then he ends up feeding with the pigs
in utter degradation. You have a very graphic description of the fall of the human race there
to the point where the man who returns to his father is unrecognizable.
And that's the situation with us. And you know from studying the hours of the passion
that when Jesus paid the price for our redemption he looked like us so disfigured he was that he
looked no longer human Isaiah 53 verse 7 says. And so the shocking disfigurement of his body
showed us graphically what our souls look like when they are degraded in sin.
Because St. Paul says he was made sin for us. He was the perfect picture of sin. It's very frightening.
And so the creature not allowing the beauty of the Creator to manifest itself in her
falls into this terrible situation. Think Jesus said, you yourself of what our sorrow is
and therefore coming to my will and together with me come to substitute for your brothers.
Come and substitute for them before the throne of the eternal one.
I want to give you Romans 8 29 to 30 there. If we have grasped in any way the extraordinary
privilege that we have in Christ then of course we will substitute for the others to try and bring
them back from their dreadful spiritual sickness. And Jesus said together with me common substitute
for all the acts which they should do for having been created as a prodigy of love of my omnipotence
and yet they are so ungrateful. So the vast majority of the human race does not in fact thank
and praise God even for their own creation. So Louisa said in one instant we found ourselves
before the supreme majesty and in the name of all we expressed our love, thanksgiving and adoration
for having created us with such an excessive love and endowed us with such beautiful qualities.
So Louisa is praying through with and in Jesus which the church has told us from the beginning
is the way we must do it. So February the 27th 1919 in the divine will there's no hindrance
to the love of God. So when Jesus finds somebody actually living in his divine will he finds no
hindrance to the work he actually wants to do both in us and through us. So Louisa says continuing
my usual state blessed Jesus in coming almost always calls me into his will to repair or to
substitute for the acts of creatures but to do it in a divine manner. That's the important thing
if we do it on a human level it is almost worthless. If we do it on a divine level
it's worthy of God. So on coming Jesus said my daughter what a stench emanates from the earth.
So I want to give you have a cook 113 which says Lord you are too holy to look upon sin.
Jesus said I can find no place for myself on the earth but because of the stench I'm forced to flee
from the earth. Now there's a big example in Ezekiel chapters 10 and 11 of the Lord actually
abandoning the temple in chapter 10 because of their sins but returning in chapter 11 when they
repent. You however Jesus said you can make for me some sweet smelling air we say incense
which might be suitable for me. If you look at Revelation 8 4 our prayer goes up like incense
into the presence of God and Sam 1 4 1 verse 2 as well. So the sweet smelling air is this incense
that might be suitable for me and you know how by doing what you do in my will all the time
that is the secret that whatever we do we do it in the divine will and not outside of it.
As you do your acts you will form from me a divine air we would say atmosphere perhaps
and I will come to breathe it and will find a place of the earth that's fit for me.
And since my will circulates everywhere and everywhere so everywhere I will feel the air that
you will make from me and it will break the bad air that the earth sends me. So I want to give you
Romans 5 20 where sin abounds grace not even more abound. So here we have the privilege that
when we do our acts in the divine will we actually create a space a locus on the earth where the
Lord can feel at home because it's his own will. Now the church is meant to be that local the physical
church is meant to be that locus where the Lord has his own atmosphere and everything to do with
his will is done and therefore that he can reign there but of course if the church is going through
a bad time and it's not really doing what it should then he mightn't be there. But if he finds
somebody living in the divine will then in that tiny little space in that one little creature
he can find his home and his space and he will still have a throne on earth. So if many many many
of us come into the divine will then his throne on earth is increased. One of my friends in the
divine will has said that what we're actually doing when we make our acts in the divine will
is that we are knitting the red carpet for Jesus's return to the earth. That he won't come to
storage he will only come to something that is divine and pure and holy. So then Jesus went away
and came back after a little while and he said to Louisa my daughter how much darkness now first
of all he said what a stench is coming up from the earth. So that stench means there's rottenness
actually there and none of us like the smell of rottenness. Okay and this time how much darkness
so the darkness is a different kingdom to Jesus. Jesus's kingdom is a kingdom of light so the
kingdom of darkness then means that Satan is around. So that's Satan's kingdom and it's such he said
that the earth seems covered with a black mantle we would say a pall of death. To the point that
they can no longer see they have either become blind or they have no light in order to see.
Now for that I want to give you Isaiah 6 verses 9 to 10. These people see and see and never perceive
these people here and here and never hear. They don't understand because their hearts are hardened
by sin and this prevents them from seeing with their eyes hearing with their ears understanding
with their heart and being converted and live. That's the tragedy of a fallen human race and when
you go to the gospels you'll find that Jesus concentrated on opening the eyes of the blind
on stopping the ears of the death loosening the tongues softening the heart giving new life.
In other words reversing this process completely so that redemption could happen.
So that's Isaiah chapter 6 verses 9 to 10. I also want to give you a Sam 115
and with regard to the blindness I also want to give you John 941 where the Pharisees said to Jesus
we're not blind surely and Jesus said if you were I could heal you but the acclaim you can see so
you have to take responsibility. So Jesus then said what I want is not only divine air for me
but also light because after all God is light. If there's no light you've got the kingdom of
darkness around and I want to give you a Matthew 5 14 because Jesus told his disciples that they
were to let their their lights shine so that everybody in the world would see and would give
glory to the Father in heaven. Therefore he said let your acts be continuous in my will.
In other words keep the lights on so you will make not only air for your Jesus but also light.
You remember the wise virgins at the wedding and they were the ones who trimmed their lamps
and they were ready for the master's return. They had their lights on the other ones didn't.
You will be my reflector he said my reverberation the reflection of my love and of my very light
so I want to give you two Corinthians 3 18 that we become like the one we worship and so if we're
living in the divine will and doing these divine acts all the time then it means that we are
reflecting his presence and his light and his love and all the rest. Even more I tell you that as you
do your acts in my will you will erect tabernacles for me. In other words a space where he can be.
So 1 Corinthians 3 16 there not only this but as you keep forming thoughts, desires, words,
reparations, acts of love many hosts will be unleashed from you because they were consecrated
by my divine will. So you see therefore that the person living in the divine will becomes
the place or the locus where the Lord can set his throne on earth and through that person light
and love and life will go out to the world and many many hosts that he will consecrate
with all of our acts. It's an incredible privilege. Oh what a free outpouring my love will have he
said. I will have the free field in everything in other words he will be able to do the works
that he wants to do and I will have no hindrance. hindrance of course comes from the human will
wanting to do something else and of course even worse from sin. I'll have as many tabernacles as
I want so many will I have. The hosts will be innumerable at each instant we will communicate
each other. Now when we go to Mass we receive Jesus and it's just 15 minutes that he is actually
with us body, blood, soul and divinity. In the divine will he's with us all the time
and we communicate each other all the time because I keep reminding people that we come
communicate. That means I receive him and he receives me. At each instant we will communicate
each other together and I too will cry out freedom, freedom. Come everyone into my will because that's
where you will enjoy true freedom. Outside of my will there are many hindrances that the soul will
find. So not only does the Lord find hindrance if we're not living in the divine will but the soul
herself finds a lot of hindrances in herself and outside of herself but in my will the soul is free.
I leave her free to love me as she wants. Now I keep emphasizing this point that the Lord wants
a genuine individual unique response from each one of us. If he was to get exactly the same thing
from each one of us we'd bore him to death. He has made each one of us quite unique
and the responses that we should give are also unique so that he has the variety that he needs
and that he can say oh that's my John that's talking.
Oh that's Miri, it's unique, it's individual. Just like when Jesus came back in the resurrection
he said Miriam and Miriam Magdalah recognized him because whatever way he pronounced it
only he did it that way and she recognized the voice of the shepherd.
He wants to recognize our voice as well and the divine will just as we recognize his.
So Jesus said I love the soul, I leave the soul free to love me as she wants.
Even more I tell her lay down your human guises, take those that are divine. He's asking us to take
up the divine level, it's really incredible. I'm not stingy and jealous of my goods. He said I want
you to take everything, love me immensely. He's asking us to love him without limits.
Take, take all my love, make it your own, make my power my beauty, make it your own.
The more you take the happier your Jesus will be. In other words he has waited all this time
for people to live in the divine will and he wants us to make the most of the opportunity
and to do the most that we can with his gifts. You remember the parable of the talents he was
upset with the one who wouldn't do anything with the talent and that talent that was not used was
actually given to the person who used their talents the most, the person with the ten talents.
And according to our way of looking at things that doesn't seem awfully fair.
But the person who had the ten talents did them actually the most work for the Lord.
So to him who has more will be given and to him who has not even that which he has will be taken away.
The more you take Jesus said the more your Jesus will be happy. The earth forms few tabernacles
from me a tabernacle is a place where Jesus can actually stay. If you read John 1 14 when
the apostle is speaking about the incarnation of Jesus he says that the the logos became
sarks that is the word became flesh with an infinite distance between the divine logos
and the flesh which is sarks and he tabernacled in our midst. He tabernacled he dwelt
but a tabernacle is something that moves from place to place.
It's not just the solid thing that you find in the church because the term goes back to the
tabernacle in the desert which traveled with the people along their whole journey to the promised
land. Now he says the earth that's people living on a level that's too low forms few tabernacles
from me the hosts are almost numbered and then the sacrilege is the irreverence that they do.
So this is the misuse of the sacraments and the Eucharist and how offended and hindered is my love.
In my will instead there's no hindrance and there's not a shadow of offense
and the soul gives me love, the soul gives me divine reparations and the soul gives me a complete
response. That's the 100% that he's actually looking for and not only that but she substitutes
together with me for all the evils of the human family. Be attentive he said to Louisa and don't
move from the point at which I call you and I want you that is don't move out of the divine will.
That's where he wants you to be 24/7/365 and he wants you to operate on this divine level.
So it's very fitting that the message that comes after this in March the 3rd 1919 is a comparison
between the terrestrial Eden and the divine Eden and what the Lord wants to tell us is that
no matter how beautiful the earthly Eden is described in the book of Genesis Satan was
actually able to enter into it and the reason is for that you have to go from Genesis right to
the other end of the Bible to the book of Revelation in chapter 12 where you hear that there had been
war in heaven and that Satan and his minions were thrown out because Michael and the good angels
actually fought and won the battle. But the extraordinary thing is you would expect
that if Satan and his minions had been thrown out of heaven that they would be thrown down to hell
but they weren't. They came down to the earth to do as much damage as possible
before they would be finally consigned to hell and that's why there is continuous spiritual warfare
going on on the earth. None of us can avoid it. If you think it's not going on there's something
wrong and so Satan could enter the earthly Eden and wreak havoc there but he has no ability to
enter the divine Eden to do any damage. So the Lord is trying to entice us now to go into that
divine Eden and stay there. So Jesus said to Louisa you are my firstborn daughter of my will how
dear and precious you are in my eyes. I will keep you so guarded that if in creating man I prepared
a terrestrial Eden that's of course Genesis 1 and 2 and for you I have prepared a divine Eden
so it's completely spiritual and it's in an area where Satan cannot enter whereas the garden
of Eden on the earth was material even though it was magnificent. If in the terrestrial Eden
the union between our first ancestors was human and I gave them to enjoy the most beautiful delights
of the earth while they enjoyed me as intervals. That's very interesting insight. They enjoyed him
at intervals because you read in Genesis 3 that the Lord walked with Adam in the cool of the day
and that language is used because if you've ever been in the tropics as I lived in the tropics for
seven years the only time you can walk is for a very short time in the cool of the day before the
onset of evening and the onset of night it's a very short time. Anybody who can walk walks at
that particular time. So Jesus said I have prepared a divine Eden for you. So in the terrestrial Eden
the first and the relationship between the Adam and Eve was human even though they had great delights
upon the earth and they only enjoyed the Lord at intervals but in the divine Eden the union
is divine therefore permanent. I will make you enjoy the most beautiful celestial delights that
Sam 36 verses 8 to 9 the torrents of his delight. Most people have the idea that God is up there
on his cloud and he's ready to punish if you move an inch in any direction they have no idea
of the extraordinary joy and peace and love and freedom and exaltation that you experience
in a personal relationship with him. I will make you enjoy the most beautiful celestial delights
Jesus said and you will enjoy me as much as you want. That's fully and completely even more I will
be your very life and we will share together the contentment the joys the sweetness and if needed
the pain because she's on the earth and unfortunately in such a broken society on the earth it's not
possible for us to get through without pain. So Jesus said the enemy that is Satan had access to
to the terrestrial Eden and of course the first sin was committed because he managed to seduce Eve
but in the divine Eden entrance is precluded to the devil as it is precluded to the passions
and to weaknesses. So here's the key I keep on saying that these texts give you the way to discern
where you're at in these writings because not only is the devil precluded but passions as well
so if you find that your passions are not brought back into God's order yet then you haven't arrived
you're only trying to come there and if your weaknesses have not come under the precious blood
of the land and surrendered to him you're on the way but you haven't arrived. Even more Satan does
not want to enter the celestial Eden knowing that my will would burn him more than the very fires of
hell. There's the insight you need. Satan had rebelled against the divine will and now in his
rebellious condition because Satan's angels were only given one chance to make a decision for or
against God and his decision was against God so it's permanent and eternal which is very frightening
so coming near that divine will would be like you and I walking towards a pillar of fire.
Now I've actually experienced the pillar of fire in Africa. You need to go to a place like
Africa to understand that the things that are described in the book of Exodus are real.
I remember the first time I saw a pillar of fire. I was so fascinated. I wanted to go towards it
and somebody grabbed me from behind and said a little closer and you will be dead. That is pure
electricity. That is pure fire. They said there wouldn't be any remains. There wouldn't even be ash.
You'd be destroyed without recognition, without remembrance.
And that's what Jesus is saying about the devil. Couldn't go near the divine will because it's
like that pillar of fire that would absolutely annihilate him incredibly. It would burn him more
than the very fire of hell and upon merely feeling the sensation of the divine will, Satan flees.
That's why there is such incredible divine security in the divine will.
And Jesus said to Louisa you will give the start to the first acts in the divine manner
which are immense, eternal, infinite and embrace everything and everyone. So she was to be the one
to start it off and then we come after her in the same vein as well. So Louisa interrupted Jesus
and said Jesus my love. The more you speak about this divine will the more I am confounded.
And I fear and I feel such annihilation that I feel myself being destroyed and therefore unable
to respond to your designs. And he all goodness added. It is my will that destroys the human in you.
There you've got a statement that you really, really must look at.
The divine and the human don't mix. The flesh and the spirit don't mix.
And so if we are to allow ourselves to come into that divine sphere we have to allow him
to annihilate the stuff of our previous life. And one of the signs that you are making progress
is that you plunge yourself continuously into your absolute nothingness.
If you still think something of yourself you haven't arrived.
It is my will he said that destroys the human in you and instead of fearing you should fling
yourself into the immensity of my will. My designs upon you are great. They are noble and they are
divine. The very work of creation oh how it remains behind this work of calling you to live in the
divine will. Now if you look at the immensity of creation and the wonder of the stars and the
galaxies and everything I absolutely love astronomy. I loved it long before I came into divine will.
I always feel that your soul needs to be liberated off the earth and absolutely enter into that
divine sphere and get lost up there. That's where you feel at home. He said but this incredible
work of creation he said remains behind this work of calling you to live in the divine will.
So getting us to live in the divine will is a much greater achievement for the Lord.
And he said I want you to actually live in it. That's 24 7 365 not just doing a few acts
but actually living there permanently. I want you to live in it and I want you to live there
not a human life but a divine life. This is on the earth. This is why the saints in heaven
look in wonder at little creatures like us little absolute nobodies living a divine life on the
earth. They would have loved to have done that if they had known it. He said it is a stronger
outpouring of my love getting us to live in his divine will. It is my love constrained by
creatures such that unable to contain it any longer I pour it in torrents towards the one
who loves me. Again that's your Sam 36 verses eight to nine. And in order to be sure that my love
won't be rejected and maltreated I call you into my will so that neither you nor what is mine may
remain without its full effect. So it's only when we allow him to let us drop the human and enter
into the divine that we achieve everything that God wants from us and he achieves everything he
wants to do in us. My daughter do not saddened me with your fears and do not saddened the work of
your Jesus. Continue your flight to where I call you. So March the sixth nineteen nineteen.
Here Jesus speaks about the different steps that he takes to make a soul come to live in the divine
will. You can't do it all at once. One of the funniest things I've heard in a divine will setting
is on the very first seminar that we held here in my own house that when the speaker had gone on
for a couple of hours and we stopped to have questions. The first question he was asked was
is there a shortcut? And I think the most appropriate reply was the laughter we gave. There's no
possibility of a shortcut. You have to go through the steps that are necessary in your journey and
those steps are not only the spiritual steps that Jesus wants us all to go through but whatever you
did in the past, whatever sins or faults or troubles you had in the past, that ground has to be reversed
and you've got to come back that journey. And so each one of us has a unique journey
depending on what we have done in the past. So Louisa said I was all concerned about my sweet
why my sweet Jesus keeps telling me about the divine will and I said to myself how is it possible
that a soul can reach such an extent and live more in heaven than on earth? Now I would imagine
that that question comes more from the priests who are talking to Louisa than from herself. I think
she would have accepted it very very simply. So Jesus said my daughter that which is impossible
to the creature anything is possible for me. Now you find this many times in scripture and
almost the same words. So I want to give you Luke 135 because that's what the angel said to our
blessed mother. Nothing is impossible with God. Matthew 19 26 nothing is impossible with God.
Mark 9 23 and 10 27. Now I could give you loads of examples from the Old Testament but I'm good to
stay there. In the Old Testament you read it like this is the arm of the Lord too short.
The arm representing the power of God. So Jesus said listen nothing is impossible with God and I
think that little statement is something you might write on a piece of paper and really look at it
by itself. It's not impossible for God to make me a saint. Now it'll take a tragedy all right
but it's not impossible. It's true that this is the greatest prodigy of my omnipotence. The
greatest prodigy is to get us to live in the divine will. So it's the greatest prodigy of my omnipotence
and of my love and when I want I can do anything if he wants it he can do it and what seems difficult
to you is very easy to me. However I do want the fiat of the creature. I do want the yes of the
creature that she lend herself like soft wact to whatever I want to make of her. Now this is our
job is the surrender and we stubborn at rebellious human beings find the surrender difficult
because we have a fear that we won't be in control and adults find that extremely
difficult that they might have to give up the control as to what's happening inside of them.
And you see this struggle that Louisa has as well it always comforts me to to read her struggles.
I want you like soft wact. So let me give you Jeremiah 18 1 to 6 if the potter and the clay
the clay has got to relact in the hands of the potter and then Romans 9 19 to 21 where Paul speaks
about the potter and the clay as well and he says something very down to earth which is that the
clay has no right to tell the potter what to do but we do one of our great faults as human beings
is to tell God what what he should be doing. So we have to give our yes our fiat like soft wact
so so that the Lord can do whatever he wants to make of us the Lord can do his work in us so that's
Ephesians 210 we are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus and I love those moments in
Louisa's writings when Louisa says to the Lord what are you doing in there inside of her and he says
I'm touching you up okay so this surrender is in fact the preparation for living in the divine
will and I want you to take this very very seriously because you may miss the point that a real genuine
fine final surrender is necessary from us our blessed mother gave her absolute one time only
surrender at the incarnation and look at all the consequences that came from it we may be inclined
to say yes I give you this bit or I give you that bit or I give you the other bit but we're not
doing a blanket yes to everything and that is the challenge that the Lord is giving to us now
please lay down your arms we have to surrender to him and it's only the surrendered soul
that finds paradise on earth so Jesus continues even more you must know that before calling the soul
definitely to live in my will I call her every now and then you see this is very important
in the beginning the Lord gives you calls every now and then and when he sees you becoming more
and more and more generous and responding more he it will come to the point where you make the
final surrender so that's why I have said to people you know who say the consecration to the divine
will frequently just surrender the prayer of consecration is beautiful but what the Lord wants
is that you would actually surrender not just say the words someday you have to say Lord this is it
this is the day I surrender I lay down my my arms I lay down my guns I lay down my scepter
I'm not ruling my life anymore you're ruling my life
so he says up to that moment I call her every now and then I strip her of everything
so to let us know that he actually really wants us to come to this point he'll start taking this
and taking that and taking the other and if you struggle desperately in him taking something from
you then it means you're not ready for that final surrender not at all but when we let him strip us
of something no matter how painful it is and we don't argue and we don't resist we let him do it
then we're coming close to this point that he really wants
so I make her undergo a sort of judgment he said because in my will there are no judgments
a sort of judgment is that you really have to come to grips with yourself you've got to face
the reality of your own person and your own history and your own weaknesses and all the
rest of it you've got to face the truth and when you let him do that judgment for you now it's all
over because if you die in the divine will you go straight up I make her undergo a sort of judgment
because in my will there's no judgments so if we're sincere about this he will genuinely bring you
through a very thorough purification so when we actually reach the point of the final surrender
in the divine will he said everything will remain confirmed in me everything will be stable from
then on judgment is outside of my will so you see it's only everything that's outside of the divine
will that needs to come under judgment and purification but everything that enters into my
volition who can ever dare to place under judgment you see once the soul goes into the divine will
in its absolute surrender then the judgment has happened and I never judge myself because from
then on we will be inseparable from him not only this but many times I make or die also corporally
and then again I give back life to her it's very interesting so in my own particular experience of
the Lord I have almost died five times he brings you right to the brink and in one case I actually
had a death experience so that you actually see the other side and he gives you a different
perspective on life I make her die also corporally and then again I give her I give life back to her
and the soul lives as if she did not live her heart is in heaven in other words he actually
lifts you up to this dimension so the world and all it stands for becomes unreal to you
so I want to give you two Corinthians five versus one to five so her heart is in heaven
and to live on the earth is the greatest martyrdom I'd like you to also read Hebrews
chapter 11 which speaks about the great heroes of old and it says that they were too good for this
earth and so they went out to live in caves and in mountains and in deserts and they were persecuted
and they were martyred and everything their homeland was in heaven they were looking for
their home elsewhere not on the earth now in this journey from wherever we've come from
into the divine will that is the reality okay that the Lord has got to bring us to that place
that we're living in heaven with our feet on earth and then he said how many times have I not done
just to you he said to Louisa these are all the dispositions in order to prepare the soul
to live in my divine will these are all the things that need to happen and then he said
there are the chains of my graces and then for her my repeated visits he said how many times have I
not given it to you everything was to dispose you to the height that is the summit of living
in the immense sea of my will therefore he said don't want to investigate it but continue your
flight now that means please don't go rationalizing it don't think about it too much just let it
happen so I think the the problem of rationalizing or thinking about it too much would come from the
priests who are asking her lots of questions so I want to give you a Sam 131 versus 123 my soul is
like a weaned child on his mother's lap so indeed is my soul